hey everyone this is Stephen Weintraub
with collider and I am here at our
studio at Tiff uh which is at the cinema
center at marble and I want to give them
a huge thank you for having us they've
been great uh and I'm here with the cast
and filmmaker behind a sing-sing uh
which is a fantastic film that is World
premiering here at Tiff I hate starting
with the generic thing but no one
watching this interview will have seen
the movie yet so who wants to bite the
bullet and explain what the film is
about the film uh tells the stories
based on a true story about a theater
program inside of a Maximum Security
Prison at sing-sing uh it is based on
really a friendship between two men who
are in this program in the prison and uh
they're very different people very
different personalities need very
different things from each other and the
program one is uh Divine G played by
Coleman Domingo and the other is uh
Divine eye played by Divine eye you've
done that before
a couple times uh one of the things I
want to start with which I found so
fascinating
um is the the way everyone was paid on
this film which is not actually about
the movie itself but the fact that it's
it's it's so different and so
interesting and cool and it makes
everyone very invested in making the
film yeah thank you that's it's
something that uh Greg cuidar and I
um we really started in our last film
jockey of trying to figure out how
there's a lot of inequality and lack of
transparency even in indie film where
we're dealing with it across the board
right now with with the strikes of
course
um and uh and so we pioneered this
um approach where everybody gets paid
the same thing everybody on crew gets
paid the same day rate or week rate uh
based on uh the SAG rates that's from
our lead Coleman all the way down to the
Pas and uh the only difference is the
time you work and then we also split the
equity with everybody body on on a very
like clear and transparent level where
it's standardized so the amount of time
you work determines how much Equity you
get I really want to say that's amazing
and um really like that's amazing and
yeah it makes such a difference in in
treating people uh treating people as
owners and as partners in the project
rather than just as people who are
working on it and then you say thank you
goodbye
um they really get to ride it all the
way through with you in a way that that
um it makes the work better it makes
them feel better it makes you feel
better and and everyone gets to if the
film wins everybody wins sure Coleman if
you don't mind me asking you've been on
a lot of sets did you notice a different
kind of energy making this because of
this radical profit participation model
that is so different than the other
projects you've worked on I think so but
it also
um points to the way that uh Greg and
Clint and Monique invited everyone in as
collaborators in every single way so
that means that every single person
truly had a voice and how we were doing
this even though we were shaping scenes
you know even the way they were built
with a Clarence and I you know I feel
like we all had stakes in it because it
was you were an equal partner in every
single way you never just felt like you
were just used for your work and sort of
sort of discarded you feel like I'm
seeing this all the way through sure
um I thought this was like I really want
to commend you guys I thought this was
so well done and one of the reasons is
because of the on location filming and
everything just felt very authentic and
that like the camera was sort of just a
silent Observer so can you sort of talk
about
um filming in a real prison and uh what
you know the behind the scenes of the
making of the movie uh listen we're in a
an actual prison and uh there's no the
windows you can't open the windows and
you look outside and there's a courtyard
with all this barbed wire on it just
gives you a real authentic feeling of
what it must be like in there
and there's no ventilation they had
gigantic fans running to keep us uh a
little bit cooled off and then when we
had to shoot the fans go off and we're
we're schwitzing to the whole it was
it was fantastic a great I mean not a
comfortable environment to uh to shoot a
film in but it did bring some
authenticity to it that I really
appreciated the whole experience yeah
for me uh it was a little apprehension
going back into prison not already
served 20 years in prison so I was a
little apprehensive about going back but
going back in this time I had a purpose
the purpose was to get this message of
who we are out to the world and what we
can do and how we can contribute to
society we needed to get that message
out yeah I think the the whole
experience I think um levels you in a
way
um and have you have even more
intentional purpose in what you're
trying to tell which is share these this
program and how beneficial this program
is to human beings inside the prison
system how art saves lives it transforms
it gives words to your experience and to
let you know you're not alone in the
world and that's what I know that my
brother over here has taken away from
the with this experience and has
propelled him into a different place in
his life I know you you get offered
scripts you've worked on so many
different projects what was it about
this project that said I absolutely have
to do this I was first sent the Esquire
magazine article that was based on you
know a story on on these men and at
sing-sing
on this program and I thought wow this
is incredible because it really
I understood that these these men loved
what I loved which is theater and
Shakespeare and how it has
transformative powers and so I thought
that was fascinating and then they
invited me in to let me know how we're
going to create this
um not only in a very like you said a
very Equitable way but also in a way
that really invites everyone to bring
their best and bring all their ideas and
shape this based on what we were all
interested in so we all have ownership
of it I think every single thing that we
did with every single day was work that
we truly all believed in and we wrestled
with it even on the day every day we
wrestle with was that scene right is it
the best expression of this world is it
honest is it is it part of the
experience in the the and is it
naturalized in a way that helps you know
bring it to film and Cinema so we we all
feel ownership of it so I knew that that
was something I wanted to be a part of I
mean as you know I you know I've been
working for a long time and I think the
things that I really care about deeply
that I want to be a part of even as a
producer as a producer on this as well
are things that I feel like change the
world in some way I think that's why I
have access to you if I have access and
I have more eyes on me I want to say hey
I want to draw your eye to this because
I think history matters I think the this
experience matters and this is what we
need more of one of the things
um is the success of the RTA program in
the prison and if and I was looking at
the numbers so many prisoners are
reincarcerated but the the success rate
of the RTA program is phenomenal so can
you sort of talk I'm sort of talking
about it already but can you sort of
talk about the success of the program
and what needs to happen to actually
bring this program to more prisons
because it seems like it's it's very
successful the success of RTA comes from
the men in RCA the people the
participants the volunteers individuals
being woken up by other men by other
people who care in prison you have
individuals who
have been written off by Society
basically once you get a sentence 20
years or whatever Society figure you're
dead already you no longer can
contribute to society
however RTA recognized that these men
still have something to contribute
and by
having volunteers that come in in in in
and actually invest their time and go
through all the things that our visitors
have to go through you know the
volunteers have to get searched pat
first everything just to come and help
us so when they do that we look at them
differently they look at us differently
and we meet in the middle they took two
steps toward us so it was our obligation
to take two steps toward them and live
this thing out and actually men have to
choose themselves to be men
if you're waiting for corrections to
correct your behavior it will never
happen
because they don't want to correct your
behavior they want you to come back to
prison this is how they keep their their
job
you know that keeps them unemployed so
correct in our behavior is not on the
agenda so if you don't come in and have
the presence of mind to correct your own
behavior
if you don't have that in you then they
will let you die you know fall through
the Wayside as far as because as far as
Society is concerned but we figure we
have something else to contribute and
what we look out and see where we can
fit in is addressing the issues of the
youth that's what I do now I I reach out
to the youth I work with at-risk teens
to try to prevent them from going down a
path that I took
so and I noticed that while working with
these teams there's a lot of things that
you know all of us can do to contribute
to our children because a lot of the
children have lost faith in us
they don't they don't they lost faith in
us because we've prayed to them we're
afraid to correct their behavior they
really want correction
but they love this guy
it's just awesome
I love them
and that's that's that's what this
program brought to me to bring to the
world we'll talk a little bit about one
of the things that's um uh I believe all
the performers outside of certain people
were all previous members of the program
who are on camera so can you sort of
talk about working
um because it just felt so authentic as
I was watching it you know can you guys
sort of talk about that aspect and what
it was like for the two of you I think
it's kind of cool the fact that you know
these men who went through this program
they had an opportunity to come back and
sort of play a version of themselves and
I think that to also shape a narrative
in a film so it shows that their their
work in craftsmanship as actors as well
so I feel like I want I don't want that
to be discounted that it was very real
and very meta and and close to the Bone
yet that took such a tremendous skill to
also be a part to go in and like find a
dramatic narrative right and and do
scene work to actually like find the
beginning will never seen again so that
was fantastic and I love the fact that
like you know we all have different
experiences and I thought we had to meet
in the middle you know some have more
experience on camera than others and
then you know we we share with each
other we're like oh I if you just did
that this and you're like oh Coleman how
about you do this I'm like great we're
sharing with each other to help each
other make the most honest
um experience possible for each other
off camera talking with these guys
getting to know them
for having lunch
and I would ask
several of them if you don't mind me
asking how did you end up here and I
hear these horrific horrible stories
about what what they did the mistakes
they made and they more than three or
four guys said to me in in different
settings
if only I had had this before
I did what I did I wouldn't be I
wouldn't have ended up in prison
uh just reaching inside of yourself to
find the man that's really in there the
lover that's in there through the Arts
it's just it's a beautiful thing and yes
every damn prison through this whole
country should have a program like this
every one of them I definitely I love
talking about the the actual editing
process because it's where it all comes
together so talk a little bit about uh
how the film changed in the editing room
and maybe ways you didn't expect uh it
was actually something this was one of
the
um
easiest ones we had to edit and our
editor Parker Laramie who who edit our
last film as well is is incredible in
helping us shape the stories the biggest
problem with this one was just an
incredible amount of material that we
had from uh from these men who gave so
much of themselves from their own
experiences um and so there's a there's
a scene in the movie that's for example
um the they're auditioning for the for
the roles in the play and everybody's
bringing their own kind of spin into
into what they're doing and I mean we
could have had a 30 minute section for
that that ends up at five minutes in the
film and the stories that they that they
all shared in in certain sections Greg
did a beautiful job in the direction and
and and in approaching each scene in
each moment to create a space for yes
what we were as Coleman was saying a
minute ago like what the original
incarnation of the scene was from the
page but then also opening it up to just
whatever truthful thing that any of the
men wanted to bring out in that moment
and felt comfortable sharing and or felt
like it needed to be there and so really
the hardest part of the edit was uh was
figuring out what to take out uh it
could have been a two and a half hour
movie easily I know this is a little bit
generic but uh it's really cool that
you're part of the Toronto Film Festival
I love this place I love this Festival
just can you touch a little bit on what
it means to Premiere the film here be a
part of the Fest that means everything I
I love I've fallen in love with Toronto
I was working on another project here
earlier this year and this is my third
time at the festival and I think it has
the audiences are their lovers of film
and they love something new and a new
way of telling story and so uh and
Cameron and this whole team they're just
the most welcoming loveliest people in
the film festival circuit that's what I
think I would agree with that it's it's
it's my second time here um and Greg's
second time here and it's just such a uh
it's got this mix of being such a
celebration of film and such a beautiful
Festival and the audiences are lovely
and the and the staff is amazing and
it's also it's got the size as well but
it doesn't lose that heart it's it's uh
it's such a wonderful Festival to bring
a film to and and let that be the
platform out into the world it's amazing
this is my third year in a row so when I
come next year
I mean I love it it's awesome it really
is
I agree these first time this is my
first time my first time in Toronto will
be the last and I'm having a great time
here I'm enjoying this Festival I'm
enjoying the electric the electricity
electric electricity that's going around
the city you know I got here yesterday
and I just put my bags down and just
walked I just wanted to go walk around
and see the people and feel the energy
you just to get the energy of the area
and with the energy of this area is
magnificent ah it's a beautiful thing
man I can't you know I just I looked out
my window and it recognized it's a giant
woodpecker outside my window I've never
seen it before really really yeah it
would pick out come on
that's the thing I love also about this
city is uh
that was not the answer I was expecting
is uh coming from America where it's a
little bit warm uh the weather here is
fantastic I love this weather I was
gonna do this all year round this
weather right here is good it's
fantastic listen I can ask you a million
other things but because no one's seen
the movie yet it's hard to get into the
specifics but I'm glad I could help
shine a light on the you know what I
mean and thank you so much we appreciate
it you know what I mean um but listen
congrats sincerely and for everyone
watching
um I absolutely recommend this film and
I really hope it gets a wide uh a way
for a lot of people to see it thank you
thank you thank you Steve appreciate it